this week on forward i jules turpak
speak with isabel bemike about nuclear
energy and climate change this week on
[Music]
hey everyone it's jules if you haven't
heard of me on past episodes i would
definitely tune into those i said last
episode it was the last time i was going
to introduce myself so you can check out
there but today i'm here with isabelle
beaumeci whose alter ego isido is the
world's first nuclear influencer and i
think she's one of the greatest
communicators that i've come across over
the past year if you were able to watch
some of her videos and not be familiar
with the current culture around short
form video today they may seem a bit
unconventional but for the upcoming
generation of voters and leaders how
she's story tells is beyond compelling
and there's a lot to learn from her so
isabelle how are you doing today good
how are you i'm doing well and i'm
really excited to have this conversation
because
well there's kind of two folds because
yang himself back in december talking
about nuclear energy it's not something
he gets into often but what he said on
the december presidential debate is on
nuclear i agree with the research we
have to have everything on the table in
a crisis situation which this is other
countries have had success with nuclear
power and the next generation thorium
protectors have a wealth of potential so
that kind of states yang's um
thoughts on this i actually grew up like
30 minutes from three mile island so for
those who don't know what three mile
island is it was a it is a nuclear
energy power plant that did experience a
partial meltdown we'll get into what
that is later it's it's a rare situation
but
i was born like you know two decades
after that happened but it was kind of
always a location point that people
would reference growing up so um just
from the media and my environment
growing up i would often hear the
negative sentiment around nuclear but
isabelle's content last year actually
opened my eyes to other angles of the
conversation so isabel i would just love
to hear what put you into overdrive to
take responsibility in this space so i
had heard of nuclear power for the first
time not the first time i'm sure
i had come across it before but the
first time i actually paid attention
was back in 2015 when a scientist i
follow on twitter called dr carolyn
porco tweeted something about nuclear
power
and much like yang she was talking about
molten salt thorium reactors which is a
technology that a lot of people are
super excited about
you know it was the first time where i
stopped and thought oh wait a second
here is a female scientist that i deeply
respect and admire talking positively
about nuclear power
um i got very curious but at the time i
didn't really have
enough time or really
you know interest to go deep and
understand nuclear power because to
understand what a molten salt thorium
reactor is you have to understand
nuclear power to begin with and that was
very complex yeah it was like a steep
learning curve which at the time i just
didn't have the interest really to go
deep but then fast forward to 2019 uh
when the australia and the amazon fires
happen
i don't know if you remember that but
yeah it was it was yeah it was very
shocking and and to me it signified it
it shifted something in my brain where
for the first time i saw climate change
as a problem of now yes there's no time
to waste versus before
you know i grew up hearing about climate
change i grew up
hearing about one day these things these
horrible things are going to happen but
it always seemed like it was in the
future and
you know in 2019 to me that was okay the
future is now
and
i always also you know it's kind of like
a childish thing but i always
had the idea that the adults in the room
were figuring this out and like people
in charge people in charge are doing
something about this right you know like
we all know this is a problem
and then i realized well not only is it
here but i guess i am an adult and it's
time for me to do something about it um
of course my skills you know my
background is i'm a fashion model so my
skill set was very limited in what i
could do like i'm not a nuclear engineer
so i couldn't build a reactor um
but just looking at my skill set and my
online platform i i decided that i
wanted to use my platform to to help
um you know solve climate change
and as i started looking into the
solutions obviously nuclear power came
back again and i kind of had this moment
of oh my god this technology i heard you
know
been hearing about for so many years
and i started doing some deep research
um
and noticed that
everything
people think they know about nuclear
power is basically wrong
and that was you know that was another
like revealing and shocking moment for
me and i asked myself why why is it
that the real information about nuclear
power is so so different from the public
perception
and what i realized is
well people don't think about their
electricity and people don't think about
nuclear energy
unless they're being exposed to it and
the way people historically have been
exposed to it is like you said it's
through accidents
it's through
pop culture so things like the simpsons
um and it's just
right and it's just uh it just
perpetuates this idea that this is a
dangerous and horrible technology
um and so i just saw an opportunity for
somebody like me
to come along and try to explain and
translate
nuclear power
to people in a way that was easy to
access in a way that was engaging
entertaining
really like in a pop culture way however
pop culture nowadays looks more like
tick-tock videos than yeah
you know than
necessarily a
tv show
but yeah that's you know it was a really
the realization that
climate change is here
we have to do something about it like i
personally wanted to do something
and
that's what drove me to to start making
this content
yeah that that's awesome and you're
you're huge on not being just a keyboard
warrior you're huge on actually getting
out there and taking action a recent win
of yours you organized the creation of a
letter that included nearly 80
scientists and academics including a
former u.s energy secretary to delay
closure of california's remaining
nuclear plant diablo canyon and since
that happened governor governor newsom
has expressed interest in delaying that
closure that is currently scheduled for
2024 or 25 2025 so very soon how did
that all come about you know and and
also just your journey yeah from fashion
model to doing this that that's huge
action that you're taking like what were
you kind of your first steps and like
okay this is something i'm super
compelled by and passionate about now
i'm going to do this
i think the timing was correct because i
came with came up with this idea
basically at the end of 2019 beginning
of 2020. yeah you know i was like okay
i'm i'm gonna be a nuclear energy
influencer because people
like influencer type of content that's
the content that people naturally
gravitate towards
i'm a fashion model so they come to my
page for that type of content right yeah
go follow me because they want to hear
my my makeup tips my skincare tips my
outfit of the days and that kind of
stuff so how can i actually
use that to to to convey this super
important message
so the time i say the timing was right
because then covet happened and
i was like the rest of the world
quarantining yeah so i just had all the
time in the world to not only learn
about nuclear power properly but then
also create you know this vision of this
outer ego slash character and just start
working on
on those videos but
it really comes down to
knowing what you're good at knowing what
your skills are
and obviously you can still learn new
things right like i didn't know how to
edit videos that well but really you're
so good at it oh thank you it takes me a
long time oh yeah yeah i feel that nope
yeah
yeah it's um you know one of those
one-minute videos takes
two weeks at least to edit yep
so it's just obviously a lot of work and
i had i had luckily i had the time
because of covid so that's how
i spent most of my my quarantine was
learning how to make videos learning how
to make this content obviously
learning about nuclear power and i i
think that the cultural shift
is extremely important right the the the
cultural sentiment about nuclear power
is what got us here in the first place
100
the idea that nuclear power is dangerous
that it's scary that it's evil
that's what brought the industry down to
a degree because what happens is you
know the super smart people who
are thinking about what they're going to
study next they're not going to go into
nuclear engineering because they feel
like you know it's an it's an evil
technology or it's a dying industry it's
not
like a rejuvenating conversation to have
with those around you yeah right it's
not a cool thing to do if you think
about it like when you know when when
you're choosing what you're going to
study you're thinking about
okay what can i do that will bring me
prestige that will
earn respect from my parents from my
friends from the community
and
if you if you're you know all you hear
about a certain technology is that it's
bad of course you're not going to go
into it so you have this like huge
you know not lack of talent there's
still a lot of talented people but there
could be so many more if the cultural
sentiment around nuclear power was
positive
and so
i'm very very focused obviously on the
cultural side
but i wanted to do even more um just
because i became
kind of a voice in in this field and i
felt a responsibility to take you know
matters more seriously and and go beyond
just the online content
so of course um i spent a lot of time in
california
um learned about diablo canyon which is
california's
last nuclear power plant
and learned about not only the his
obviously you know the fact that
california is a leader in in
the climate space
but also about the history of diablo
canyon and all the political
implications of that it is
probably the most politically relevant
it is the most politically relevant um
power plant in the united states nuclear
parkland there were huge protests in the
in the 60s and 70s
to not to not build it like something
like hundreds of thousands of people
attended those protests wow
and
so it is like it is a symbol it's a
symbol of nuclear power it's a symbol of
of california obviously
and when i looked into the details of
why it was being closed it just didn't
add up there was no technical reason why
it was being closed the plant
operates has been operating for decades
without any issues
you know
super safe
so the reason why i was being shut down
was mainly political wow there are some
you know the
the excuse being given for it being shut
down
is that it uses uh once through cooling
system to cool the plant down which is
it sucks water from the ocean
and then it
it brings that water back
certain degrees like
five degrees warmer or something
and then
that is the excuse being given it
because that affects marine life has
some impact on plankton and
some types of fish
however
and i understand that that's a concern
right
we can't just look at
technologies through one lens
of course there are some impacts but
then the question is what are you
comparing that with
right like what are the other impacts of
actually closing this plant down and
replacing it with fossil fuels 100 so
i just i just got very passionate about
it and
you know called a bunch of
pro-nuclear organizations and asked them
what are you doing about diablo canyon
and they all told me the same thing they
all said
don't waste your time
people have tried for so many years to
save this plant
there were campaigns back in 2016.
do not waste your time this is not going
to happen you said nope
yeah i was like
oh
interesting you say that
well
in my mind you know and i'm not just
being like a like a endless optimist who
is just
like no i can make this but it was just
i was looking at the reality of how much
everything had changed throughout the
years the decision to shut down the plan
was made in 2018
we didn't have an energy crisis in
california
or climate change it was yes of course
it was being talked about but we had
those fires
that really i think
pushed people to to want more you know
to want more effort from our governments
so i saw that the situation was
different and maybe there was an
opportunity to bring this conversation
this conversation back and i think that
now with gavin newsom saying that he's
open to it it proves that i was right
because
one of the things he mentions in this um
l.a times piece where he you know opens
up to the idea of of extending diablo
kenyon's license
is um the energy shortage that
california has
so obviously i think the situation has
changed and
you have to be able to assess these
things
at different times like maybe didn't
make sense to launch an effort to save
diablo canyon
in 2019 yeah but you know
in as little as a as a year things can
change very very drastically and now you
have obviously the war in ukraine and
how that's affecting public perception
as well because people realize that
we need energy independence so a lot
lots of factors go go into it but
yeah it's been super gratifying to see
that
he's open to it now
[Music]
life can be overwhelming we all know
this
often we burn out without even realizing
it so
that can end up being lack of motivation
or irritability or fatigue or
just shortness things like that and i
want to talk to you guys about better
help because it is a type of online
therapy that wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself and helps you just
kind of work through your thoughts
personally i use better help use it a
lot during covid but just to i called it
my steam valve just to blow off some
steam just to collect my thoughts talk
about things i don't necessarily want
to talk about publicly
with someone online securely privately
personally so betterhelp if you don't
know is a customized online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera even
if you don't want to it's private secure
it's convenient easy to schedule it's
awesome it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours so really really easy
to start so listen our listeners of
forward podcast are going to get 10 off
their first month that's betterhelp.com
yang so check it out that's
betterhelp.com
yang take care of your head guys check
it out right now betterhelp.com yang
[Music]
it's crazy how much cultural timing
plays a role in things because like yeah
something can seem so obvious to you but
until like the masses catch up with the
messaging and find it compelling it's
like that's when it's like the time to
go in on it and i i completely agree
with that so you talked about your
experience you know you were seeing the
wildfires happen and your um sentiment
towards climate change kind of
exacerbated in terms of like how
how close to home it is and how soon
this is going to be affecting us it's a
very weighted conversation on everyone's
shoulders and for the average person you
know your mind goes to corporations and
kind of these situations that feel
larger than life in a lot of ways and so
something like nuclear energy feels you
know just as you know nuanced and
complex to the average person
it's highly technical it's highly
dynamic in terms of the conversation
around it and most discussed good or bad
typically amongst the highly educated so
when you were going in and learning more
so about more about nuclear energy what
did you see as the major discrepancies
and messaging around it that you want to
tackle to make it attractive to the
masses as well because you've been so
good at communicating the messaging
around it
obviously the biggest one is the
how dangerous it is
the
normal perception is that it is the most
dangerous way to make electricity that's
what people think they automatically
automatically think of chernobyl of
fukushima um three mile island even
though there weren't you know any deaths
related to it it was an impact it was an
event that impacted the community like
you said you grew up there you grew up
listening you know those negative things
so that's where people's minds
automatically goes to
and that's normal that's a normal human
bias
it's called actually the availability
heuristic which means whenever
um which it's kind of similar to how
people fear airplanes
uh even though airplanes are some of the
safest forms of transportation however
when an airplane goes down you know you
see it on the news
it makes the headlines it sounds scary
and so people irrationally fear
airplanes more than they fear driving
their cars even though they're like the
likelihood of them dying from a car
crash is much much higher yeah um so
it's a very it's a very common bias and
of course like i said if your only
exposure to
a technology is the negative things it's
the bad headlines
it makes sense to think of it in those
terms
however
we thankfully have data
that tells us what's you know what's
actually true in the world
and when you look at the data around
forms of
energy you know ways to make electricity
nuclear power is consistently one of the
safest ones it's actually comparable
it's very very minimally higher than
than solar
wind or hydro
and of course much much lower than
fossil fuels
so
again that was one of the biggest things
i wanted to address was this myth that
it's actually that it's dangerous or
that is the most dangerous way to make
electricity a curious thing an
interesting thing is that
we've had much larger
hydropower dam accidents than we've had
nuclear power accidents
there was a
there was a dam in in china
that collapsed and flooded a bunch of
small villages you know that went
downstream for from it
and it killed hundreds of thousands of
people
yet
it didn't make the headline we don't
have a netflix tv show about it you know
we don't have we don't have like a hbo
special on the on this damn in china so
there's something also that's very
intriguing and interesting and
it's culturally um
sexy in a way let's talk about nuclear
power extreme
right
right yeah it's it's it's a weird
interesting phenomenon
but that was one of the main things the
second thing i really wanted to address
was the waste
perception
yeah it's a big one
it's a big one you know people
always bring up ways and i
i'm ashamed to say i've been working on
a video about ways for
two years
um not not a shame you gotta get that
messaging right now i get it i get it
yes and the format and all of it i've
been playing a lot with different
formats but
you know the waste is also something
that took me a while to to come around
because i i kept thinking wait but this
sounds really bad
um
and i think where i landed with it is
basically you can't you can't analyze
the technology in isolation
right you can't just be like
is nuclear power bad
yep
well
compared to what and in what way
every technology that we create has some
downside right
like renewables are great for some
things they have downsides
um
fossil fuels have allowed our
civilization to to get to where it is
today
you know we we've had tremendous
improvement in quality of life
for people across across the world
um you know
high energy life it is the same as a
high quality life so fossil fuels have
enabled that however it comes with all
this problem so it's all a matter of
like
a comparing the technologies with what
we currently have
and just being able to to analyze in
context so anyway so the waste issue is
okay we have
you know this incredible technology that
makes a lot of electricity without any
carbon emissions
but you have
like
a small amount of very radioactive waste
that comes out of it yep
the question is
is that bad
and of course it sounds bad because it's
so radioactive that if you and i came
and touched it when when it comes out of
the reactor we would die
but
how is it handled um has anybody ever
been injured from it
how could somebody be injured from it
um and so when you start looking into
those things you start realizing that
the fear is more of like this
hypothetical
apocalyptic
end of the world scenario where
civilization loses you know the ability
to communicate
and
and then all of a sudden you come across
this this cast then you open them and
you touch the thing and and you eat it
and then maybe you die yeah
but in reality what it is is like this
ceramic pellets that go into the reactor
to make
electricity
after they're done they come out
they're like
heavily you know it's it's something
that's like super technologically
advanced
um
the people who work at the power plant
take it out of the reactor
put it in a pool to cool for like five
years
and then take take it out of that pool
and put in like this giant concrete
casks where it's like bolted
and
waste
tons so you can't just like
roll up to a nuclear power plant and
grab one of those things like this is
like seriously heavy yeah concrete
shielding casks
that are so good at blocking radiation
that you can you and i can literally
stand right next to it and touch it
and be totally fine we would not be
you know any no radiation would come out
of it yeah
um and by the way the nuclear energy
industry is the only energy generating
industry that is actually responsible
for its waste
so when you compare to fossil fuels it's
just spewing into the air yeah people
let's talk about that yeah like killing
nine million people
a year from air pollution
plus causing climate change which we
don't even know how many people it's
going to kill but just affecting the
whole world so
you know do i
what should i choose
you know this thing that's literally
killing millions of people and causing
climate change or
this thing that sounds scary but it
actually has never hurt anybody or the
environment
and is being very well managed
that's how i ultimately landed on it yep
um
and you know there's like a deeper
conversation about what do we do with it
long term
but we don't need to get into those
details if you don't
oh no no so like
what i found found interesting you
brought up quality of life and when i
first came across you and it was like a
few months later i had gone to your
website and you you know how you have
some um kind of basic breakdown videos
and the one was a i always get this
youtube name wrong it's such a good
channel it's like
i don't know how to do that
you know
i want to create a petition to change
the name because i'm like this cannot be
good for you guys like yeah seo all that
like so i have such a good channel but i
just cannot like pitch you to other
people but the video was talking about
you know because you know again for me
climate change is super overwhelming but
it kind of brought it down to four
different things the first two are you
know it's it's hard because it's human
nature at this point and population size
and population growth and population
growth doesn't like economic growth then
the two other things of the four factors
are things that you know we can change
and nuclear energy can have a big part
of it as energy intensity
and emissions per energy unit produced
and i think a lot of people yeah get
kind of mixed up of quality of life and
kind of standard of living so standard
of living you know deals with the access
we have to things you know humans aren't
going to take steps back when it comes
to innovation that's just like in our
nature but um more comfort
yes yes but it's like this thing now
like you know you don't you don't hate
on you wind or solar or any of that
stuff you know that that stuff that
there's already a positive sentiment
towards so that's why you're focusing on
nuclear and i don't think people realize
like how much we are innovating you know
it's not going to stop again it's in our
human nature and like we have to
fight when it comes to fossil fuels and
everything like that we have to fight
the problems that arose from you know
human tech with today's tech and that's
where nuclear comes in so i'd love for
you to hear about that like the balance
of you know us be still being able to be
human focus on innovation because you're
really big on you know pushing against
all the negative sentiments towards tech
and you know the balance of how nuclear
is there to help that
well i think there's a very common
belief in the environmental community or
in the climate change community
that
the way to solve climate change is
basically to dismantle
our society
reduce energy consumption and go back to
a way of living
that
consumed less energy i think you know
that is attractive to some people
i think
good luck
convincing seven billion people to do
that
and i also think it's a bit of
a
privileged
out of touch position
that usually comes from people who grew
up in developed countries
who don't understand what a low energy
life looks like yeah
they have a fantasy in their mind that
it's going to be this beautiful utopia
and you know
solar panels and rolling in the grass
yeah rolling in the grass and whatever
and it's not you know it's like
it's a lot of hard work and it's um
not having proper heating in your home
when it's freezing outside
so you have to sit in front of a
fireplace and inhale particulate matter
and it's not having
air conditioner during the summer
and basically not being able to sleep
because it's too hot yeah not being able
to sleep has all this impact in our
health
it is women basically being
condemned
to working at home forever because they
have to
you know do their laundry by hand
because they have to do the dishes by
hand and because they have they just
have to dedicate all of their time to
doing house drawers
because there's no technology to take
over that
and i say these things because these are
all things that i personally experienced
growing up
in brazil yeah 90s and it wasn't we you
know i i was born in a small where i
lived
for a long time in a small town
so
it wasn't like i was super poor
it was just that that was the way things
were done and this is the way things are
done for billions of people in the world
right now so this idea that somehow
we're going to reduce our energy
consumption i think is
first of all
sure start with yourself like yes you're
free to do whatever you choose to do
but don't
force that on other people especially
don't force that on
people in poor countries who
for the first time in their lives like i
knew people back home that saved money
for years to be able to buy a laundry
machine
you know
and oh man when they bought the laundry
machine it was you know it made their
life so much better yeah so we have to
be able
it's not just about climate change it's
also about energy inequality and so we
have to be able to
understand and have compassion for
people who don't have the things that we
have
so
the question now is how do we create a
high energy life for everybody
without destroying our planet which is
you know if we continue with the current
technologies
mainly fossil fuels then
we there's a very high chance we're
going to destroy ourselves but
thankfully we have all these
technologies you know and that's one of
the reasons why
you say i don't hate on on wind and
solar i think it's
dumb we're going to need all of it
i don't understand people who think that
we should only do nuclear power all over
the world that's the only technology we
should do no we're going to need all of
it because
not only do we need to replace all of
the current fossil fuels which is like
84 of our electricity comes from fossil
fuels that's a lot
not only that
who knows what our our energy needs are
going to look like in 20 years
like who 20 years ago could have
predicted you know we're going to create
this technology it's called
cryptocurrencies and we're going to need
like a [ __ ] ton of
computer power to mine them and you know
it's going to create
emissions as high as certain european
countries yeah no one would have
predicted that technology
now
do i think
you know is crypto a good or bad thing i
don't know i don't think too much about
crypto but the question is
this is not the first or the last
you know energy intensive technology
we're going to create so we need to
optimize for a future of
energy abundance but that energy has to
come from
carbon free sources and of course
through solar there is wind there is
hydro
there is there is all this like little
geothermal some of smaller ones like
tidal
but it would be absurd of us
to completely ignore
one of the biggest sources of clean
energy that we currently have which is
nuclear power
because we learned about this technology
through the simpsons
you know it just doesn't make any sense
wait what did the simpsons do on it i
honestly didn't even see that what did
the simpsons homer simpson
works
who is you know not a very bright person
works at a nuclear power plant he's an
operator at a nuclear power plant and mr
burns who is the evil guy in the show
owns the nuclear power plant
and he's always trying to
put waste in the city like that's you
know the
in every episode i think there's some
reference there's some negative
reference to nuclear power oh my god
that shows i'm very uncultured when it
comes to the simpsons but like
but it is of course it's not just the
simpsons you know yeah all these other
things like like the chernobyl hbo show
and now the um through my island on on
netflix and all this kind of stuff it's
just like
we can't ignore a technology because
we've been
misinformed
through pop culture yep for the past few
decades
and and to that point because you know
again like me saying i grew up 30
minutes from three mile island i didn't
really necessarily know that there's
only been kind of what three
potential meltdown situations in history
what what is kind of the history there
and then you know because growing up
it's again because i would constantly
hear references to three mile island it
felt like that was the norm for
nuclear power plants almost like kind of
clarifying what the history is with the
discrepancy like the issues that
happened
[Music]
so there are three main nuclear power
accidents right you have you have
chernobyl which was actually a very bad
accident
um
this was in the soviet union okay um it
was a it was a reactor design
that doesn't have a containment dome
what that is is basically like a shield
around the reactor so that in case there
is an accident it prevents radiation
from
leaking into the environment
so the the design at chernobyl did not
have that it was soviet union so they
were very
harsh
they didn't tell people
that the accident had happened oh god
some people were being exposed to
radiation
you know for days after they were like
inhaling um i think it rained as well so
you know they're they're obviously just
being exposed to it
um you have three mile island which was
like you said a partial meltdown
no attributed deaths to it
and then you have
fukushima and fukushima is the most
recent one
when was that as in recent years where
was 2011. okay and like um yeah for
everyone three mile island was like
1979. when was chernobyl chernobyl was
like 86. okay
and so
we have this three major accidents you
know in terms of um death
toll chernobyl was the worst yep i hate
talking about these numbers because
one it's very hard to know the number
the exact numbers yeah two i feel like
it's minimizing the deaths and i
absolutely don't want to do that i don't
recognize the accident i don't minimize
the deaths it was horrible i wish it
hadn't happened yeah
idea in culture is that maybe millions
of people died from it
hundreds of thousands of people died
from it
the official number
of deaths attributed to chernobyl
directly attributed to chernobyl is 55
period
55 deaths including
the personnel who came into the plan you
know when the accident happened to kind
of
um calm things down yeah so 59 people
plus
there's an estimation it's really like
it's very complicated radiation
like really complicated science
but the basically
the most credible estimate is that maybe
a total of 4 000 people will die
from
an early cancer caused by
radiation from chernobyl that's an
estimate it's highly debatable some
people think it's
exaggerated some people think it's too
little so we don't know yeah
okay
you compare that with that single um
hydropower dam
in china
that killed hundreds of thousands of
people
right
it seems small compared to that
um of course again wish
hadn't happened but we have to put these
things into context yeah and it seems
trivial compared to fossil fuels
yeah um you know
that's always like the thing it's like
you know the sense of negative sentiment
but it's like
we are predominantly using fossil fuels
right now like what is this conversation
yeah yeah and maybe the conversation is
because well we don't need nuclear power
you know we just
do other things we should just do
renewables
i don't think that's
i don't think that has proven to be true
in the past few decades
um
quite the opposite i think that we've
seen that we need something like nuclear
power
to
work with renewables
and then you have but then back to the
accidents you have fukushima which you
know is the most recent one
um
some people died from the evacuation
from
you know whenever the plants
and by the way this accident was
some people say
you know typical the company that runs
it
was
was warned of something like this for
many many years
because they
basically what happened was there was
this giant earthquake
probably the biggest in japan
um the earthquake
made the reactor shut down like it's
supposed to like it's designed to do
and the reactor was shut down but you
need you still need water to cool the
system down because it's pretty hot and
if it keeps getting hot and hot or
hotter you can you can create like a an
explosion a hydrogen explosion or you
can create a meltdown yeah um so in the
case of fukushima the the earthquakes
shut down the react the all the reactors
um
however then the sun and the the diesel
generators which are supposed to keep
pumping the water were working properly
but then this
tsunami came and the tsunami inundated
the basement level which is where all
the diesel generators were
and so that damaged the diesel
generators
and they couldn't pump cooling you know
water into into the reactors and so they
kept getting hotter hotter there was a
hydrogen buildup and explosion and
that's what you know that that was the
accident
the interesting thing is
there was another plant that was
actually closer to the epicenter of the
earthquake
that got equally hit by the earthquake
and a tsunami
but their their sea wall was higher than
fukushima's
and so the reactors shut down properly
the diesel generators kept cooling the
system and everything was fine
and in fukushima's case they had been
warned for for many many years that
their civil war was too low
so basically if there was a tsunami it
could cause exactly the problem that
that you know
had been caused
so
then you have all these evacu you know
you have all these people being
evacuated some of them died in the
evacuation process um there's
one
death that has been attributed to
exposure exposure to radiation from
fukushima from a worker who was at the
plant at the time and he died in like
2016 or something from
lung cancer or something like that
but there is
you know there are no projections of
more people dying from exposure to
radiation
and now i think actually this this week
people have been given um
the green lights to go back to the to
their homes in a lot of the evacuation
zones in fukushima
so you have this
you know three accidents
um
very scary yep you know people had to be
evacuated people lost their homes
i i think they're bad
obviously
um
i think that
you know thinking that nuclear power is
actually the second largest source of
clean energy in the world
um right after
hydropower
and comparing to fossil fuels
it doesn't seem as bad
yeah but of course how many uh plants
are there in the u.s
there are 98 reactors i'm not sure
exactly how many plants
because some plants have two reactors
some have one but there are like 98 oh
okay
so yeah you have like 90 you had
you had like over 100 at some point 100
reactors in the u.s for
you know over 40 years
and you had
one accident that didn't cause any
deaths
france has never had any major accidents
um several countries um
and so
yeah i think it i think it sounds bad um
the goal should be zero accidents for
sure
but i think in context it's still better
than what we have now and what countries
are kind of
more so fully deep diving in nuclear
energy right now and that you're kind of
looking to as a good point of reference
we're not unfortunately russia and china
okay make sense very big
yes they're they're kind of leading in
terms of building and also exporting the
technology
so china
plans on building 150 reactors in the
next 15 years jesus which is absurd yes
but they're getting very good at
building them fast and cheaper obviously
france is now changing the tone and
they're back you know france is one of
the biggest nuclear countries in the
world actually they get 75 of their
electricity from nuclear power wow and
they kind of turned away from it for a
while
basically influenced by germany
and now
with the
energy crisis in europe plus the russia
ukraine war
they're they're coming back to nuclear
power so that's exciting to see as well
but those are some of the biggest kind i
mean poland now wants to build nuclear
reactors poland is primarily coal
which is the worst of all you know
possible energy sources
yes
i can't even believe that we're still
burning things too yeah yeah yeah it
feels like i don't know it just reminds
me yeah like early 1900s
right yeah like really
like we burn
dead um plants
and
and dinosaurs
yeah actually i got called out because i
put post a meme about like uh fossil
fuels being dinosaurs and people like
it's actually most mostly plants i'm
like okay i'm sorry never saying that
again
[Music]
you know before diving nuclear energy it
was something that you you were um you
know
presented to and you ended up going back
to it but when it comes to climate
change and when you're first seeing like
the wildfires again i think like people
it's crazy how
desensitized everyone is coming to
things because you know the news cycle
and the trend cycle is so quick and it's
like you know the climate change
conversation is by no means a part of
the trend cycle and uh what was it last
month or two months ago it was like the
nasa scientist peter thomas uh protested
fossil fuels by blocking the entrance to
a jp morgan chase building in la and
jake for everyone like jp morgan chase
is known as like the worst fossil fuel
bank in the world they financed uh
51 billion worth of fossil fuels in 2020
so that was actually you know in the
headlines for a decent week but again it
kind of fizzles out what were what was
like the media that you consume that
really made you realize you know this is
something i need to act on now this is
whether it's whether people want to be
really a part of it like you are
but like just something that really made
you like internalize the reality of
what's going on i can't think exactly of
one thing for me it was just the images
of the fires it was
it was especially a video of this native
brazilian woman in tears you know her
village had been burned
and um
for me was the visual of the fires that
that trigger that thing and
that's the thing though you don't know
like the brain is so fascinating
and we don't know why the neurons make
connections in
the way and the time that they do but
sometimes
you can hear about something for many
many years you can hear about a problem
for
a decade and you just yeah don't think
about it too much and then all of a
sudden boom you know this idea comes and
connects with me
yeah for me i think just the images of
the fires
were
i think images are very powerful mm-hmm
it's an immersive experience of the
situation so much more than words and
numbers
you know having which is why also
nuclear accidents are very dramatic
you know you have these images of
explosions and
and um
yeah the fires were like
what really triggered me
and
this is something that i've had recent
personal beef with away from like kind
of nuclear energy but talking about the
climate change conversation
you've mentioned in your videos for
example what what is like the fashion
industries for example contribution
to you know the current climate change
situation
and they're not the worst yeah obviously
like energy production transportation
those are the big ones yeah for sure
yeah but of course the fashion industry
does thus contribute
and it's
it's just a really hard one because
especially now with instagram
yeah especially instagram tick tock as
well but i feel like instagram is much
worse in like shelving products
and influencers just
posting pictures with different outfits
every day and
the what's what's the name of the videos
where they try a bunch of stuff on the
halls the halls
you know man those halls they're cool
but like
like sure you're gonna buy some other
you know
outfit or skirt from
like a fast fashion company
yeah that's why
i really wanted to talk to you about
this because of course you're a fashion
model you have
much respect for the industry i have a
lot of respect for the industry i have
like friends that are just like you know
super talented when it comes to fashion
like you know creating pieces and
everything but yeah there is this side
of the internet that has really
exacerbated yeah the fast fashion
industry and it's weird amongst young
people because you know climate change
is a huge conversation amongst young
people and then there's this
contradiction of um i think you had seen
my tweet on this it was like sheehan is
now sheen which is a fast fashion
company in uh china is now worth uh has
a hundred billion dollar valuation and
it's grown like crazy and the
predominant
target audience is gen z they say that
loud and clear so it's like this weird
contradiction and i don't know that's
like super overwhelming to me like it's
just something you look at you're like
uh but like i would love to hear like
your relationship and approaching it
like you have a respect for fashion you
have a love for it but also yeah that
relationship of balancing that i i find
that fascinating and to me what you know
that the fact that she now has you know
it's one of the largest fashion
companies in the world and
their their audience is gen z crazy and
gen z are the ones complaining the most
about these things right i think what
that tells me is that it is hard to make
these decisions yeah i think people are
evil i don't think people are i'm not
perfect i buy stuff that's for sure
the best for the environment
and
at least i'm not preaching about it but
but i think i think what that goes to
show is that we can't expect
people to make those decisions because
it's first of all
it's cheap to buy these clothes
right you're like you you want to look
good you want to look cool
um
you're not going to buy something that
you're going to wear for a season
that's going to cost 200 because it was
made with this like organic cotton and
has all this
like this amazing supply chain
um you know the people are being paid
fairly but you as a as a you know as a
young person
you can't afford it
so we have to be able to make those
things more affordable
for people and i think that that's where
the fashion industry really could come
in and i don't know what the
i don't know the answer is because how
do you make something
that's affordable but that is also has
good quality products in it and that
also pays everybody throughout the
supply chain a fair
you know a fair price i think it's very
complicated i think the fashion industry
one is very complicated which is why i'm
kind of excited about things like
digital fashion even though they're not
something that you can apply for your
real life in your everyday life
at least for online for um video games
yes you can you can use them you can use
that at least
for a couple of photos so you're not you
know just constantly trying to get new
outfits and i think it allows you to
wear things like couture pieces that you
would never be able to afford but you're
paying like
eighty dollars a hundred dollars to have
a photo with with like a super cool
crazy piece that you would never buy in
real life
so i think that's exciting and the
fashion industry really has an
opportunity to try and figure that out
but there is also no incentive because
as you said you know
these fast fashion companies are the
most profitable ones yeah so why why
would they
and probably that their success is the
fact that they can turn out things very
quickly and cheaply so why would they
be incentivized to
to change their practices there's like a
chicken and egg problem like the fashion
industry has to do something but then
also they're not incentivized because
people keep buying those cheap things
well i think it just goes back into the
argument of like why we need something
like nuclear because we do have to fight
today's tech in terms of economic growth
tech is at at the core of everything uh
something like sheen is pumping out like
i think a thousand styles per day or
something like that like
that that stuff's not that's not gonna
change so like we have to fight tech
with tech in terms of balancing it all
it's not necessarily fighting but making
a balance and you know the things like
wind solar everything the natural stuff
is great and like you said we we need
that in tandem with everything but it's
it's not going to do the job fully so we
definitely do need nuclear in that fight
and so what do you kind of see as the
core things for like young people who
like me were
really introduced to a more nuanced
conversation from nuclear from you
online um what do you see as the core
things to root for when it comes to
nuclear is it keeping the current plans
open and also vouching for more and what
kind of what else what do you think
[Music]
keeping the current plants open is a
no-brainer and it's like the bare
minimum
and this is something that
some anti-nuclear people agree on
you know the in the people who are
anti-nuclear but are more concerned with
with climate change
will
absolutely agree that we should keep
every single existing nuclear property
open of course if it's not safe if it's
meant to be shut down for technical
reasons
no but in the case of plants like diablo
canyon they should absolutely stay open
because what happens right now is
even if
that you know electricity output is
replaced with renewable energy which in
most cases it's not historically when a
nuclear plant shuts down it's replaced
by fossil fuels yep it's exactly what
happened in indian point in new york
even though the state for years said
it's going to be fully replaced by
renewables the next day the the plant
shut down it was replaced with natural
gas wow and it's still to this day you
know so anyway
but even if you were to replace it with
renewables you're still staying in place
instead of replacing fossil fuels with
with clean energy so we we cannot afford
to be closing down nuclear power plants
that's the bare minimum
and then the next thing in my opinion is
you know if you're a young person going
to university like
what are some of the fields you can
study that you can
work in nuclear energy yeah if you are
you know if you're in a neighborhood
that is thinking about building a new
nuclear plant which is not really
happening in the us but if you are like
how can you galvanize the the community
to actually support it
um ask of your politicians you know like
ask their position in nuclear power and
vote for people who are pro-nuclear who
were
openly pro-nuclear i think that was you
know andrew yang's
he gained a lot of fans when when he
voiced his support for nuclear power and
i think the administration now is
actually pretty pro-nuclear power as
well but asking a few of your
politicians and then just
i think spreading the message is the
most important thing for sure so
you know if you don't want to do any of
those things because they
might be too much effort just talking to
your friends about it
um
engaging in conversation and telling
them like no actually you know i just
think that as well but when you look at
the data it's pretty clear
that we need nuclear and that it's much
much safer than people think
so that's honestly all i ask of people
who
have changed their minds just
start engaging conversations and try to
change that culture because i think it's
one of the most important pieces
and when looking at the future of
nuclear so one of the quotes from yang
like you said was next generation
generation thorium protectors have a
wealth of potential yeah how are you
seeing like the innovation within
nuclear um
just like get better as we go so the
thorium one is funny because it's we
have a joke in like people who advocate
for nuclear power that you like
thorium is the gateway drug oh really so
yeah so most people learn about thorium
and they're like oh my god this is you
know this is what we should be investing
in and then you start learning about
nuclear power and you're like oh this is
definitely hyped and like
like it's an okay technology but it's
not the holy grail that people make it
out to be that's fine
yeah it's it's really funny because i
wasn't one of them too like i came into
the play for because of thorium molten
salt or reactors
um
but there's so much innovation going on
you know like a lot of these new reactor
designs
they are
even safer than traditional nuclear
which is already pretty safe compared to
you know fossil fuels but these are even
safer so
you know you can you can even not have
people working in the reactor it would
shut down automatically and there's
minimal risk of a meltdown happening
because of the different fuels different
types of fuels different like
temperatures of fuels and stuff like
that
um
so even say for
smaller you know easier to build
cheaper
and one really cool thing as well is
that some of these advanced
nuclear designs
can actually use existing nuclear waste
as fuel
because
existing nuclear waste is over 90
reusable uranium so it's like 96
reusable uranium
so what people call nuclear waste is
actually just like an amazing source of
energy that we just haven't tapped into
so this new reactor designs could
actually use that as fuel and then the
nuclear waste that you have to dispose
that off which is already
small would be even smaller
um
so those are all super exciting things
that are happening now i mean these
desert
things that are being you know designed
and
hopefully built within the next 10 years
awesome yeah well that's amazing a lot
to look forward to a lot to root for and
i think um in terms of kind of a closing
out question it's more so like uh you
know life advice in the way that i love
how you approach your platform online
you know you're not a full-time content
creator you're using content online to
yeah as a gateway almost to get your
messaging out there to connect with
others in terms of what you really
believe in you also have something else
full time on the side when it comes to
being a fashion model
i think a lot of um i i'm sorry for
those listening out i say young people
sometimes out of just like habit and
reality this is um
something that everyone can attain to
everyone can tap into
um kind of like just how you're
approaching online when you you have
this passion and like how you look at
social media because kids today i feel
like looking at it all is like all or
nothing like oh i want to be a full-time
content creator and that's all i want to
do and they don't really have this like
backup plan in reality what the lifespan
of a content creator an influencer is
like i think the average is like 36
months or something like that and i love
like your your
multiple faceted approach of like yes
people want to come to you for you know
makeup tutorials or fashion hauls or
whatever but you connect all worlds um
of your life and create this really
compelling and unique content you know
you have a storytelling talent um not
everyone has that but i would love to
hear like your take on that and your
experience of just really tapping into
all facets of yourself online
it's kind of the future of
just work in general
i believe that people have all these
different interests and talents
and
a online education
helps you
maybe develop one of the
more than one of those skills or
interests that you have
and you can i think nowadays with
technological um advance and the way
people work from home so they don't have
to commute to an office it allows more
free time
to do more than one thing now i have to
say in my case it's very unique because
modeling is is something that
is very much not full time in that i
don't work every single day
and even when i do work when you're on
set you're kind of hanging out
a lot of the time because you're just
waiting
to be you know photographed
so it's it is
my i think my case is very different for
most people but i do see a lot of people
doing you know several things
um
that they're passionate about and i
think that
just explore different things you know
like when i had this idea for ice
i mean it sounded insane
yeah
you know i was i was telling people like
oh yeah i'm going to be a nuclear energy
influencer and i'm going to make all the
videos and
you know it's going to be like a makeup
tutorial then it's going to emerge and
talk about nuclear power and people are
like okay
yeah they're like are you okay
i have a friend of mine who
i gave a ted talk recently and we were
talking about it afterwards and um
he you know we were just like chatting
he said i have to say when when you
first told me of this idea i was like
yeah honey okay sure
and then now just seeing you on stage
with this you know the branding behind
you and all these things like crazy
yeah you just have to try things it
could have been a huge fake failure but
that's also okay like you cannot be
afraid of trying different things
because you don't know what's going to
stick
so yeah just follow your passions do
different things and and try different
things online like who cares
in that yeah that ted talk did ted talk
didn't drop yet correct no not yet how
was that you don't have to tell us the
details but just like the general
experience oh my god it was so stressful
it wasn't the best company i've done in
my life really how long was it like 10
minutes it was 10 minutes yeah but i was
enjoying it a month and a half before oh
my gosh most people have
six months yeah
for the ted talk
so i was invited a month and a half
before i basically had to drop
everything else in my life and just
focus on that and so i would wake up
every morning and just sit in front of
the computer and type and type
i rewrote my speech
20 times
including completely changing the the
format of the speech
five times at least
um
so it was a very very stressful
experience
um it was a very interesting experience
because there were some people who were
in my session or there was one person
who was in my session i'm not going to
name names nope
but
[Laughter]
this person
had talked to you
yeah is it very anti-nuclear power oh
and they made it very clear when they
came off stage
by not congratulating me or you know so
there was like some drama behind the
scenes
um
i made a collaboration actually here i
have a can yeah i did a collaboration of
a drink like a clean energy drink but it
was it was a great experience and i feel
like my message landed with a lot of
people awesome the best compliment i got
afterwards was when it wasn't even a
compliment just a comment it was
you know i used to be negative about
nuclear power but now i'm curious yes
exactly that's all and that's it
yeah that's it i don't want you to be
like yeah nuclear power like you don't
have to be the biggest fan you don't
have to like drop everything you're
doing
just open your mind and start learning
for yourself
yeah that's that's the most important
part is that curiosity element because
if you're not curious it's like
everything's basically shut off but if
you're curious like you'll listen to the
other side of things so yeah exactly
yeah that's awesome but um i think
that's all i have to talk about today
unless you have any closing comments any
like last sentence you want to see say
to people about nuclear energy and that
you know about your messaging um that's
all i got today no i think i said it all
okay cool and where can people find you
online
[Music]
my last name i have to spell my whole
name
yes word letter for letter
okay so on instagram you can find me at
we'll put it in the description huh
please put it
i'm like i don't want to bore people to
death by
spelling my whole name
or isotope but oh you can go on
isonope.com that's pretty easy yeah
that's the gateway for everything i love
now i love saying gateway since you said
that i'm like yeah
just go to isotope.com and go to icedubs
instagram twitter and all of that stuff
and
yeah i'm not super consistent with the
content but i try to be
you know mindful and and making good
stuff
no no that that's the last closing
statement i want to say today too again
back to being you know content creator
influencer i love that you are quality
over quantity we see a lack of that
today and that's why like people play
into extremes everything like that
because it helps the algorithm like i
love the quality of your stuff and it's
really good stuff that lands with people
anyway so it gets that reach so i want
to say i appreciate that too and a muck
of content today it is very refreshing
so yeah thank you all right thanks
isabel and yeah everyone check out
icydope.com and
her platforms thanks
thanks for those
[Music]
you